will the new Netflix series about the
Man Without Fear be terrific like Frank
Miller's daredevil or will it be ghastly
like Ben Affleck's daredevil find out on
this week's episode of angry news first
your comments masinloc her rights can
you do a video about how to make a
proper Green Lantern movie hey Mason I
was pretty excited about the original
version of the last one which had a
script by Robert Smigel triumph the
insult comic dog and it would have
starred Jack Black but then instead of
making an out and out comedy DC decided
to just make something laughable so 13
episodes of Netflix is daredevil are
going live simultaneously on April 10 I
plan to pace myself I'll take a 15
minute break between episode 6 and
episode 7 I don't want my body diffuse
to the couch again like when I binge
watch house of cards season 2 now I know
a lot of other commentators out there on
the interweb a matoub zor obsessing over
Daredevils outfit in this new series why
is Matt Murdock wearing a black dread
pirate roberts get up where's the iconic
red costume or the classic yellow
costume for that matter take a chill
pill you geeks that has nothing to do
with the success or failure of the
series who cares what he wears see
superhero costumes don't interest me
they did I just ok ok they don't
interest me much the real key to the
success or failure of this new daredevil
isn't going to be wardrobe it's going to
be how well the series portrays the key
supporting characters no not Daredevils
buddy foggy Nelson her love interest
Karen page not even his mentor stick I'm
talking about Wilson kingpin Fisk and
new york city itself daredevil comics
had terrible villains still flying frog
but King Finn kingpin was a cartoonish
character who gradually got more
menacing as the series progressed in the
new show Wilson Fisk is played by the
excellent Vincent D'Onofrio good sign
and he'll apparently get a story arc
just like Matt Murdock will even see him
courting his future wife promising now
daredevil stomping grounds to the hell's
kitchen neighborhood of New York and to
capture the spirit of the comic
it needs to be a filthy CD violent place
if they're doing it right viewers should
feel like they want to take a shower and
burn their clothes after watching and it
should not be glitzy grimy like like on
Gotham like some high paid art director
spent hours carefully besmirching the
set and bathing it in shadow so that
it's the most gorgeous urban blight
you've ever seen my take I think Netflix
will pull off the portrayal of kingpin
but faceplant on the setting I hope I'm
wrong what do you think let me know in
the comments hey remind me sometime to
tell you my theory about how dare devil
was obviously inspired by the Japanese
movies about the blind swordsman
satelitte you well I mean I can't
explain it now it takes several hours
for me to lay out my case point by point
I don't even have my powerpoint
presentation I'm intrigued by the way
that Marvel Netflix is going to be sort
of like a pocket universe extended
miniseries version of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe instead of doing a
few big budget movies about individual
superheroes that culminate in a monster
budget super team movie Netflix is
giving a series 24 of the more gritty
and down-to-earth heroes of the Marvel
pantheon and then they'll all team up in
a defender series that could be amazing
or it could be pure torture the big
problem with the Marvel movies is that
they undermine their storylines by
trying to cram in all of this setup for
the next installment in the franchise
does that problem go away if you have 50
episodes to fill or will they just stuff
it full of 10 times as much
cross-promotion and set up I'm just
happy to see superhero shows that don't
have to be structured around commercial
breaks what do you think let me know in
the comments subscribe to the wire
channel on YouTube and click on these
tiny versions of me over there to binge
watch more angry nerd episodes hey maybe
if one of those versions of me got hit
by gamma rays and the other one got
injected with Super Soldier Serum we
could form an angry nerd super teen ah
let's be great our arch-nemesis could be
like like Galactus and Lex Luthor oh and
michael bay oh hey this is perfect this
Solly will somebody get me Stanley on
the phone this I
dia is going to make me rich